uh so Jose Aldo also had a box match
over the weekend he won by points and
then since then I guess he's been in
talks with Floyd Mayweather to do an
exhibition bout and in this article he's
saying like it's an exhibition for him
but it's not for me I'm gonna actually
go you know punch him he's gonna
actually try to take his head off yeah
yeah and Floyd's like whoa whoa be cool
man beef cool but apparently yeah Floyd
said that what's going down his side has
agreed already my side too Aldo told
mma's fighting uh we're now waiting for
the promoters to get the deal done you
digging that or how do you feel about it
yeah for listen for all I just want to
make all the money I don't know how much
money that makes I don't know what kind
of numbers Mayweather's do at this point
he's fighting YouTubers and training
Partners in 20 mil for the last uh
listen If Aldo can make that much money
God bless him I hope he makes it